[Music]
so we're going to talk about
time-consuming algorithms
maybe you've met some first of all let's
get to know each other
so I'm low on pika you can follow me on
twitter my handle is Picard Paris so my
name speaker I live in Paris that's why
I'm a software engineer and I joined
Google a few months ago and I work for
Google cloud platform and in previous
life I created b'keen so that's an
e-book company I've been working for 17
years in the e-book market so I'm one of
the ebook dinosaurs I've worked in
hardware and software and with bikini I
created a highly available eBook
ecosystem so eBook device ebook apps and
ebook stores as well and a long time ago
in 1999 I co-created the first device in
Europe but I'd like to have a sense of
who you are so just a few questions so
among you who are developers nice so
let's say 3/4 who is already using cloud
services
ok 2/3 now that's a pretty common who
has already used Hadoop or spark ok less
and less let's say 50% and who knows
bigquery ok so a few so before we start
I'm going to make you a promise
sorry we are going to to to so here are
the takeaways I wanted you to have today
so we're going to talk about time
consuming algorithms we're going to see
how we can run this algorithm in
parallel we are going to see how you can
the results from this code and we're
going to also see how you can analyze
the result in real time okay and here's
the promise I want you to make you
before we start no computers are going
to be harmed during these sessions so I
tagged it a serval as well so what does
it mean I came here I only have my
laptop right and we're going to use a
lot of computers during this session and
they're not there for the time being
them's there somewhere just sleeping and
I have not configured anything except
that I have an account and I have code
that I prepared for you okay so let's
start so first example I'm pretty sure
you have made that you have a
computation that's going to take an hour
so as a developer the joke that you make
most of the time is the following
ok that's coffee time I'm pretty sure
yeah you take the chance to have coffee
I like coffee but after some time it's
going to be maybe too much also maybe
you're going to take this as an
opportunity to do something else so
you're going to lose focus and be less
efficient and so you your work is going
to be fragmented so let's try to find a
solution to that as of today all of our
computers are several CPUs or logical
CPUs within the same core so if I take
this example I have a one hour
computation if I can cut it into six
chunks so I'm going to end up to be able
to run my computation my one hour
computation in 10 minutes right I'm
going to run this 10 minutes over six
different cores but what if my
computation takes one week so this in
this case I'm not going to be able to do
it even though I have a few servers on
at home or in my company
there's no way in the best case it's
going to take maybe
few days so there are really
side-effects when you're dealing with
such time intensive workloads you have a
broken schedule so it has a big impact
on your project as well let me give you
an example so back in in booking we we
had some huge huge meta data for coming
from publishers so gigabytes of data and
you had to process them sometimes you
had to fix them and I had to batch that
took two days and there was no way I
could I could do it differently at the
time it took two days so it's bad in
some ways so first of all you have to
wait for two days before you get an
actual result so that's that's not very
efficient and also when you're starting
to implement your solution most of the
time you have bugs so when you realize
that you have a bug and you just spend
two days on a computer to process your
data let's imagine that you just wasted
two days and worse you know computers
sometimes fails fail and if you're just
running out of memory whatever after one
day and a half then you just wasted one
day and you have again okay
so this is just to give you an example
and by experience when you have such
delays you are just generating
additional delays as a project manager
and this has an impact on the users as a
whole so for instance in the case of an
e-book catalog users could be waiting
for two days to have an up-to-date
catalog or to have up-to-date reviews
not very good but it could be worse if
you are a searcher you're working let's
say on finding a cure for a disease if
you're wasting weeks like this this is
not going to be very fast and worse
there are some users that are waiting
for you
to get this cure so here you know the
clouds have quite a few CPUs so if I'm
taking this time a one-week computation
I split it into roughly 1000 chunks then
I'm going to get back to my 10 minutes
so I calibrated this presentation for 10
minutes because this is roughly what it
takes me to get a coffee ten minutes
okay so one solution to distribute our
code is spart so we spark basically you
can run it locally but then you can
distribute your code on master node and
on X worker nodes so here we're talking
about servers or CPUs or virtual CPUs
the nice thing is that it's an open
source project maintained by Apache
there are many many contributors you can
get it to run in Python in Java in R and
in Scala so I think it covers many of
your use cases and this is pretty fast
it's let's say if you compare it to
Hadoop let's say it's an optimized
version of Hadoop I'm being very basic
here it's processing the data in memory
and so as a whole it's 10 to 100 times
faster than Hadoop ok so here we have an
open source solution to this view code
we'll see later how we can do it but we
are going to need CPUs right so another
solution a complement to that is data
proc so data proc is a module within the
Google cloud and it's actually a managed
solution for the spark service and this
is why again you're hearing or reading
about service and as you can guess also
with Google this is highly scalable so
as we say a picture is worth a thousand
words but in my opinion live demo is
worth even more
ok so let's have a live
together so I took this example for a
time-consuming algorithm so we're trying
we're going to try to estimate pi can
you raise your hand who knows exactly
what this is about
I'm pretty sure many of you I've seen it
okay just okay so I'm going to explain a
little bit what it is yeah you can read
the code okay so this is a mathematical
statistical experiment you take the odds
many darts you have a square you draw a
circle within the square
it works with a quarter of a circle -
it's the same you throw the darts
randomly and you keep the dots you you
you count the dots that are within the
circle if you throw many many darts you
are going to go closer and closer to
estimating the surfaces of the circle
and the square and the ratio between the
two is PI over four so if you just
reverse the equation you get here how
you can estimate pi just by counting the
dots that are inside over the total
number of dots that have been launched
okay you can have a look on YouTube
there are nice girls
we took a journey in new park and during
one whole day did Detroit launching
actual darts it was not random so they
they struggle but they roughly came
after launching hundreds of maybe
thousands of times there are dots
roughly they came to an estimation of
3.1 but at the beginning it was two
three or four only so very very it's a
very slow implementing it's a very slow
method - to estimate pi in this case I
calibrated it this way I am taking 10
million samples so I am flowing 10
million darts and on my computer it
takes roughly 5 seconds ok so this is so
this is the code that you saw I just
added some some output I'm going to
launch it
okay so let's wait a couple of seconds
and just to make sure that you get is
seeing the result okay so in six seconds
I launched ten million darts and I got
3.14 which is okay but this is random if
I run it again maybe I will get three
point two or three point oh okay
so now if I have the same algorithm but
I'm going to run it many times so let's
say 1,000 times so this is going to take
5,000 seconds over an hour okay so I'm
not going to run it because obviously
you understand what it is but just to
show you here I'm just repeating the
same experience 1000 time okay so now
we're going to start distributing our
code to be able to make this one-hour
experiment in a short time
so for that we're going to create a data
proclo stir so that's a spark cluster
with a worker node and sorry with the
master node and worker nodes so here I'm
going to use the web console and I'm
going to create the cluster so to make
it under one minute we're going we're
going to choose 256 CPUs so I'm choosing
the region it's going to run in Europe
West so that's in Belgium actually I'm
going to keep the master node as a
standard machine
I don't need discs so I'm going to put
the minimum 10 gigabytes and I said I'm
going to choose four times so for
workers of 64 CPUs so that should be 256
and I'm also choosing going to choose
the minimum size for the desk ok and
that's it I create the cluster it's
going to take
a minute about a minute our big minutes
it's between 60 and 90 seconds and
during this time we are going to see how
we can prepare our code to run it in
parallel in this cluster so I take my
small small experiment here you have to
realize that this time we're using the
random method and it's going to be run
to run on many many CPUs so I need to
make sure that I'm not using the same
random values on otherwise I will get
exactly the same result so here I have
just adapted the methods to get a random
seed and this way I will make sure that
I'm not getting the same result
everywhere and then this is just spark
so I will not get into details but spark
allows you to create an RDD a resilient
distributed data set so this is an
abstraction to allow you to run your
code the method here map is the one that
is going to distribute my algorithm so
the the Montecarlo dot experiment
overall the course and then when
everything is finished I'm going to
reduce and so by adding all the result
all together and like here I will get
all the dots that are inside with the
just this simple code and the final
result is is just computed the same so
here the cluster is about to be finished
okay so you can see it's consuming very
little 1% ok
my villains are ready so you see I have
my master node and for workers of each
64 CPUs I'm going to SSH so here nothing
exists is before that this is a very
convenient
this is SSH within the browser so this
is a chrome window that's been opened
and I'm going to have access to this
virtual machine and so it takes it takes
a few seconds going here just to copy
taste to code the code you saw okay
just copy everything so here I have my
window on the master node I'm going to
launch PI spark so this is Park for
peyten
so likewise he take a few seconds to
boot and I'm going so this is a console
within PI spark and I'm going just to
copy and paste the result my code sorry
okay so here it's like a Python console
I paste okay and here what you see is
that I didn't provide many settings so
by itself my algorithm is being
distributed so it it hasn't started yet
it's uploading the code everywhere and
okay and now you see the results coming
back to my master node and here this is
what remains to be distributed and maybe
there are there are few reminders to ya
before it's actually finished yeah and
this is the end of my code and here you
see I get pi is 3.14159 this time in 39
seconds I launched ten or so thousand
ten billion dots so that's one way so
let's exit so here everything is manual
as you can see I'm going to delete my
cluster because there's no no pointing
in in keeping all these CPUs okay and
now we are going to the next stage so
what we've done is we've launched 10
billion dots but we didn't keep the
results so everything is lost
so the next step is to keep everything
in a database or a data warehouse and
bigquery is the other solution it's also
in Google Cloud and it allows you like a
database but scalable and real-time it
allows you to to keep all of your result
very easily so here I have nothing we're
going to create it I'm going to enrich
my matrix so here I'm going to specify a
timestamp a duration for each experiment
and and my main result how many dots are
inside and how many doors have been
thrown so this is how we are going to
create this data warehouse so this is a
Python code this one so you see this is
exactly the code I showed you I'm going
to launch it okay so that's number five
okay so here the small fightin code is
going to create the data set because it
doesn't exist and then one table within
this data set so it should come okay the
data set is created and the table so
let's have a look in big queries I'm
going to refresh my project okay so here
I have my Monte Carlo data set and
within that I have my experiment table
and here you find the schema so now I
have a data warehouse and we can push
data to that so so the next step now is
the experiment but the one that is going
to last for one week okay so I hope you
have your sleeping bags and everything
right yeah you didn't get in the memo
okay so the next step is to create this
time the same cluster as before but to
go faster we're going to create a
cluster with over 2,000 cores
okay so this time to show you also how
you can better integrate for instance
with continuous integration we're not
going to create the cluster manually we
are going to create it with a simple
command like here G cloud data Pro
clusters so that's the main common
prefix for everything related to cluster
clusters and here we are going to D to
say okay create cluster 2048 in this
region and let's have a master node like
this with 8 CPUs and let's have 32 64
cpus worker nodes so i'm going i'm going
to copy paste the command and here okay
let's do it so this is just like before
but this time it's it's going to run for
60 to 90 seconds in parallel and during
this time we
you see the next step is to keep
adapting our algorithm so here you can
see that I have had a timestamp at the
beginning of my algorithm then I am also
computing the duration of my experiment
and instead of returning the single
result I'm going to return my three
matrix and here the main loop is just
adapted slightly to be able to collect
at each increment each iteration my
results so here I'm still calling map on
my Monte Carlo experiment but instead of
computing the result I am collecting the
result and Here I am building rows so I
am streaming the rows to bigquery so let
me show you the whole code okay so this
is what you saw here I have a method to
stream to bigquery so basically I am
just making JSON data and here by
calling that big hew insert I am
throwing all of my Jason so roughly
every five seconds I am going to to
stream all of my JSON data to bigquery
and again with continuous integration
here I made a slight chance I am going
to use that as a job so I am NOT going
to login into PI spark I'm going to
launch a job to by spark directly so I
don't have to connect to to the console
anymore so let me show you how it looks
so G Claude data probes and here I'm
going to submit a Python spark script to
this cluster and just by specifying my
Python code okay so before that let's
check yeah I have my 2048 core cluster
so here it's waiting for me to to get
something to work on so as you can see
the worker mode so I want SSH into
this VM this time and I have all my
workers with 60 core in each VM
okay so let's copy paste the command so
so you understand this is my job here so
this is the algorithm that we've been
enriching every time and I'm going to
launch this job here okay so the major
command is the Windows command to
measure everything
so you see lunch I'm giving my Python
script to this cluster and I specify
that it says Python spark script
okay so let's wait a little bit so right
now it's being distributed to 2000 cores
just like before and the job is running
so here the code is getting everywhere
and we're still we're beginning to get
results okay and there are many stages
that are going let's I think there are
around 50 iterations that are going to
be run okay let me check that so it
means that we are already getting
results so let's let's check now in big
query what we have so because I told you
is a data warehouse but it's like a
sequel database so we're going to create
this this table so let me show you what
we can do okay so let's have a look yeah
at all the data that we have so with
this simple query okay so the the data
are being streamed live to this to to
this table and I can prairie it
in real-time so here we have already
12,000 experiment that have been run you
can see the duration for each of them
that the times them that the sort of the
start time of the each experiment and
you can see the results okay so yeah
we're streaming live we are querying it
in real-time and then you know better
than me I guess many of you are data
scientist you can do whatever you want
under the partial results and of course
in a couple of minutes everything will
be finished but so I must have a few
Democrats let me check you here
so for instance I can have a sense of
the result an estimation so here as you
can see I know that pi is between this
value and this value and on average I
have this so which is already quite good
and let's try another one
save query is okay you can also if you
know sequel or equivalent you can get an
estimation of yeah the different
percentiles so so the nice thing is that
with all the metrics that you can stream
then you can analyze pretty much
anything so here with the condyles
method I am going to ask okay let give
me the first ten percent of the result
and strip everything like like an
Instagram so let's write it okay so you
see it's it's very fast in two seconds
and so here again if I was to to draw an
Instagram based on this you get a sense
of the different values and let's run
the last one
also for the duration because this is
running on virtual CPUs so you have no
idea what's going on so here I wanted to
level to have an idea about what's
happening for my different experiments
so let's run this and I will have a
pretty good idea about the different
duration so here as you can see it's
running between source some experiments
are going very fast so this is in a run
to to do to do the PI spark overhead so
what some are doing very fast but most
of them are going between 5 seconds to 8
seconds ok and you you can have the
distribution so let's have a look at the
yeah I think we are starting to see the
end of the experiment here you can see
the job that has been launched so you
have a history you can check everything
later on if there's an error you can
check it here here you still have my all
my instances and what's happening here
ok no it's going to take a bit more time
to finish but but as you can see we have
been able to get results analyzed in
real time and the experiment is still
ongoing and it could go for hours but
actually hours here represent weeks ok
so to wrap up here are the main
resources you need unity no spark so at
Apogee dot org data proc and bigquery
are under the under the Google thought
the cloud.google.com main site and I
hope you so my goal by coming here was
to inspire you guys I hope this gave you
a few ideas of how to accelerate your
developments and getting result faster
feel free to ping me on my Twitter if
you want this code to be
open-sourced or whatever she want I
could put it on github this is my first
talk about this subject and I joined a
few months ago so three weeks ago
I barely didn't know about data probe so
this is just to tell you how fast you
can go up to speed with this technology
okay so that's it for me thank you very
much thank you so much any questions to
our Lauren regarding the proposed part
okay yeah there's question most of the
computations requires some kind of
external libraries or other dependencies
and does this product support custom
images or something like this blowing
workers I think so I've not played with
it but it does support by standard all
the mathematical so numpy and so on so
if you are a data scientist it will it
will work right away and by the way here
I have seen so my code is not optimal it
could it could go a lot faster I am I
have an overhead because I am streaming
the data every five seconds so I could
do it differently and likewise the
random method I'm using is not it's not
really that good is not that random so I
could converge to the right result a lot
faster and and by that I would need to
use none by the numpy library so I can
do it but here I wanted to stay as
simple as possible so this is why I kept
that code but I will check on an and
we'll publish in my Twitter account your
question so I do have an idea but which
you have a library in mind maybe older
than Empire or okay okay I'll check
I'll check that okay so you can connect
on Twitter about that
so Lauren thank you so much for coming
and well if we talk we have a break
right now a longer break there's coffee
out there
you